hello again Sporty Spice Melanie C is
back it's been 26 years since the Spice
Girl started storming UK charts I cannot
believe it's 26 years uh well they
really haven't stopped since as a group
or individually her new album also
titled Melanie C released last week
features collaborations with Nadia Rose
sha and longtime Spice Girls Ally Biff
stanner uh let's take a listen to the
lead single In and Out of
Love like no one's
here I feel the heat of your skin you
pull
me I go in and out of love never get
[Music]
enough such a distinctive voice isn't it
I'm very pleased to say Melanie C joins
us now uh Melanie I've got to say real
pleasure to have you on the program this
morning I've got an incredible amount of
love in my ear from my producers and
Technical staff certainly a lot more
than the politicians we've had on the
show this morning though You' you'd
probably expect it let's start with the
album itself tell us a little bit about
it oh well this album I'm so happy to be
able to release it you know I did
question whether the timing was right
obviously it's such a difficult year for
everybody it was inspired by an
incredible 2019 being back on stage with
the Spice Girls I also did a world tour
of Pride events with Sink the Pink an
East London creative Collective so I had
this wonderful year of positivity and
Performing and it inspired me to make a
record which was really reflective and
positive and empowering and now here we
are in 2020 and I'm actually pleased I
can I can offer some entertainment
hopefully some distraction to try and
lift Spirits in such a weird time H well
I can promise you you have have improved
the mood of my producer David 100% just
by appearing on the program this morning
um but you've worked with a number of
different artists on the album This Time
younger artists as
well yeah it's been wonderful actually
because this is my eighth studio album
as a solo artist and I think as an
artist it is important to keep listening
to younger voices you know they have
such different influences a great energy
and that collaborative process has been
really exciting for me and I think it's
really fresh in the sound it feels like
a new chapter for me it's quite dance
inspired pop records and I just can't
wait for everyone to hear it and I hope
they enjoy it as much as I've Loved
performing it um you mentioned of course
everyone's plans for 2020 obviously fell
by the wayside with with the Advent of
covid-19 I mean did you have to do any
work on the album uh during lockdown or
was that was that all done in
Dusty you know we were at the finishing
stages of the record so luckily most of
the physical work had been done I had a
couple of socially distanced vocal
recordings but a lot of the mixing and
mastering was able we could could do
that remotely you know it was a
different experience and it was
challenging in many ways I think the
biggest change for me has been this the
promoting of the album I was in
Australia when covid really hit I was in
LA when we were about to go into
lockdown so I had to rush home and get
creative on how we promoted it and you
can see there this is um the video for
In and Out of Love which we shot during
lockdown actually when when um
restrictions had eased a little so I
think you can see I'm a meter away from
dancers at all times we were at a
beautiful theater at Alexandra Palace we
were lucky enough to secure that place
and um yeah we've just been trying to
carry on and create some really
interesting content for everybody as
we're all stuck at home and kind of
getting through this this year yeah Ju
Ju Just on that of course you're you're
part of an industry that really is
suffering a bit at the moment
particularly in terms of of live music
but but also one presumes as well in
terms of in terms of recorded music
you'll have been speaking to to to
younger uh people younger people coming
up in the industry I mean how how bad
has it got from from your
perspective oh it's so it's so
concerning you know I feel so lucky I am
in a position where I I can weather this
storm you know for now things are okay
we're planning to T next year but I
worry about Young artist I worry about
venues people who work in touring
whether it's at the venues the backline
crew musicians it's it's a very very
difficult time for so many Industries
and this is one that has hit hard um
Melanie you mentioned a couple of
moments ago you you your commitment to
lgbtq your your appearances at at Pride
around the world in fact this is
something that you you you you've long
campaigned on I mean what is it about
your music the the music of the Spice
Girls that really seem to be embraced by
this
community I think being back on stage
with the girls last year we really
realized the impact we've had on a
generation and what the Spice Girls
means to so many people and I think our
individuality coming together being so
different but having that Unity making
us really strong was something that appe
appealed to a lot of young people and
appeal to the lgbtq plus Community
they've been incredible supporters of
myself and the spice goes forever and
it's so lovely to be an ally to the
community and and you know be able to
repay some of that wonderful support
that they've given me and the girls yeah
it is amazing when you think of your
pictures are funny
sorry I I was just about to say I mean
26 years ago I mean the Spice Girls came
out and and still of relevance did you
ever think actually when the group came
together that you would be able to have
an effect on social issues uh like
sexuality that you would be able that
you would now be in a world where people
are talking about hashme too and and
rewinding you know the best part of
three decades to you guys talking about
girl it's incredible you know we're so
humbled by it and we feel so privileged
that we had the opportunity it wasn't
our intention at the beginning but it
quite quickly came to light that there
was sexism within the industry within
the entertainment world and we felt like
we had a platform and we had a voice and
it was important for us to use it but we
never knew it would have such an impact
and kind of permeate through these
Generations you know we're so proud my
daughter's 11 she loves the Spice Girls
she's full of girl power so hopefully
this will go on for many many years to
come um you you've also been very candid
um about issues around mental health
your own mental health as well we have a
a mental health expert on the program
tomorrow viewers are going to be able to
to put their question because of course
during lockdown look hands up pretty
much all of us have had a little wobble
from from from time to time if if you
had one piece of advice based on your
own experience for someone who might be
confronted with issues like that at the
moment what would that
be oh gosh I have to admit it's been a
difficult time personally for me um I've
had some very low points during this
year during lockdown and
quarantine I would say talk speak up if
you can't speak to a family member a
friend somebody close to you reach out
to somebody professional there are great
resources online go to your GP if you
can um but definitely speak up and
please be kind to yourself you know
you're not alone We're All in This
Together yeah we certainly are and yeah
be a rare person indeed who didn't share
some of the the experiences that you've
had during the lockdown period as well I
have to end though um melan with the
with the most serious questions of all
um is there any chance that we're going
to see a Spice Girls record anytime soon
and uh can you get Victoria
involved well I think hopefully you will
see a show before you see new music uh
we had an incredible time doing shows
last year and I am dying to get back on
stage with the girls and I know the
girls feel the same so yeah watch this
space we'll do the the best that we can
to get out there in and spread some more
joy yeah you do that Melanie see you
spread lots of it already this morning
best of luck with the album thanks so
much for joining
us thank you take
care what a lady